if i could jump over to that question
about privatizing certain things uh
look we went in uh during the first what
do we call it incursion into iraq um
i had uh i was i was out at that point
but we put a bunch of guys we put a
bunch of guys into uh into iraq um at
the behest of some uh clients that we
had that were
going to be doing infrastructure work
out there in iraq you know they already
knew it you know and and so so we had
been doing some things for them
elsewhere and they said look from a
security perspective you know can you
help us out and so
we started putting people in there um
really at the same time or just slightly
ahead of when the troops went into iraq
and
we're a private business right so we
start building up an operation out there
and this is early days this is before
blackwater became a household name and
and and
um so we watched that sort of that
private contract or private security
industry build in iraq over a few years
and
um
it was it's a bit of a [ __ ] show because
it's a private business and so we saw
people looking and going i could make
money doing that so you had you know a
large number of moocs with no experience
thinking i'm going to start a security
company and they were banging around
washington dc where we had an office and
we'd come back i'd come back and say oh
could you meet with these guys they want
to you know talk to you about you know
lobbyists
well these these were guys that were
pseudo lobbyists or they were just they
were just guys are hanging around
washington and thinking i'll bet i could
get a contract somewhere and this is a
good business so you started getting all
these companies showing up and i
remember talking to some of these
companies and you know whether they were
british or american whatever and
and look you don't have an endless
supply of trained people with sufficient
experience to operate in a hostile
environment like that
um whether it's providing security or
gathering intelligence or whatever so
that bar kept lowering and i'd talk to
somebody and they'd say yeah i was um
sbs you know out of the british you know
teams and you think no you're not you
know because we've got the former
commander you know working with us and
he's never heard of you and
you you this would happen time and time
again so eventually people were hiring
just you know people with no experience
no business being out there
and that's when [ __ ] started to happen
and so then what happened when that
yeah kerfuffle started was that the
government got involved and said look
we've got to you know we've got to
regulate this we've got to come up and
so there was this effort with the
private businesses now starting to see
wait a minute we're our business is
being threatened because now the
government's looking at it you know
maybe the government's going to step in
and start you know regulating this so we
started meeting as private contracting
companies saying we've got to form an
association here set some standards
right and
well you're doing that because you're
trying to protect your business you're
not necessarily doing it because you
know none of these guys really cared
about that but they were doing it so
they wouldn't lose their contracts so so
some of the government i guess my point
being government involvement in there
was actually an important part of it
right because it helped the regulation
the regulation um the
you know setting some standards getting
some of the idiots out of it um so i
you know again i'm conflicted because i
can see both sides so after after they
came in and and you guys set the
standards how did it work out in
comparison um you know what it it worked
out better because there was more
policing of
of uh protocols of hiring of
requirements there was more you know
so i i don't know it's it's uh it was
one of those things i just wanted to
raise the point i'm you know i don't
want to disappear down that route
companies like that like if i'm
halliburton and i find out that my
security team was maybe substandard not
as good as they pitched me in the
powerpoint deck and i'm hiring them to
protect basically u.s civilians who have
agreed to go into a hostile theater and
work on a an electric power grid project
right right so now i'm a little bit
concerned by that and this kind of
didn't that help the companies weren't
they appreciative that now they have
some sort of reliance and standards
right that my civilians that are over
there working on a dam were kind of it
was a lot of infrastructure yeah there
was no and that's that's a good point
and they did appreciate it and it was it
was beneficial to them um
you would like to have thought that they
would have been you know look we were
the companies we worked with they were
very clear about we'd expect
you know the following uh in terms of
standards and and you know it but i
guess you know my point being is that
if you leave it up to private business
it may not there's always that statement
oh private businesses have to run things
right they're going to be more efficient
than government
yeah
you know but you there is a place for
government at times or it goes the other
way right because whack and hut has
actually hired remember wackenhut hired
to do the private prisons in the u.s and
they've actually hired their own
lobbyists because they like tougher
criminal laws because it makes an influx
of prisoners that need a place to
which means you build another prison
yeah so so for private business to
uh to benefit from wars that concerns me
because you're you know you know what
i'm saying that concerns me part of me
is kind of a military industrial totally
exactly i was going to go there and that
but but you know not somebody bobby can
you increase tyler's audio as well like
10 percent
you know but but for me so then the
other side of it if i'm being a devil's
advocate to myself is it's going to
happen anyways because again on the
inside that's on the government hey you
do this i'm going to give you this hey
lobby is coming in i think the problem
here
for that to work out is if you
eliminated lobbyists a lot of things
would be more honest
and transparent because these guys that
are making 10 20 million a year a
lobbyist is making it's one of the
highest paying jobs in america by the
way if you enjoyed this short clip click
over here to watch another short clip
and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]